welcome back we are so excited to have
our next guest back on the show that's
right he is a grammy-winning rapper
entrepreneur and executive producer of
the stars hit series power
please welcome the talented and ever so
charming curtis 50 cent
jackson here
[Applause]
i got like every piece of bling i could
out
for you
and then you come out in the hope
diamond little little piece of loose
home
um you know the last time that you were
here
we played this game that is so fun and
we loved it so much it's called
is 50 thrifty
and we loved it so much that we thought
we'd start the day again with that but
that does not look
thrifty
i can't hip-hop if they don't see the
like the little
the little blinking
really
[Music]
oh my god
[Laughter]
you anyway so playing with me
[Laughter]
[Applause]
okay
let's play all right
so how our
running game works and i hope we do this
for many years to come i could see us in
wheelchairs doing this game and having
fun together
many years from now is the point it's
better way better than your regular game
show it really is and you're gonna uh
look at two items
we're gonna guess which one is more
expensive and which one is thrifty so
we're gonna start here with these robes
do you like our nice chagrin leathery
masculine beautiful brown tones we
picked for you yeah this is nice
i think number two is more uh expensive
so
you think number two is more expensive
yeah is he correct
yes
that's absolutely right so
this robe right over here retails at 49
and this robe right over here retails at
182 dollars
[Applause]
okay next we have the loafers this makes
me so happy
playing this i definitely don't got a
pair of these but this is gonna be
this is gonna be great let me see if i
can figure out at least i think these
are more expensive because this is like
penny loafers they're supposed to have
yeah i put a penny in all right is he
correct
yes
okay
this
slipper over here retails for 12
and this one retails for 145.
okay next we have two purses fitty what
do you think
um
i don't feel like neither one of them
leather
wait let me go
nah i think this one is more expensive
he correct
number one retails at 17
and purse number two that fitty
corrected correctly guessed is
195 dollars
that's a lot of lemo okay last but not
least we have this beautiful lotion and
if you would kindly pump it into your
hand
here you know what i'm gonna have to
take that off of you again so you can
really you know
one smell way better than another one
[Music]
i'm going with the first one
so number one is your guess for which
one is more expensive yeah is he correct
bottle number two
is the thriftier option and it retails
at five dollars but bottle number one
which 50 guests correctly is the lux
version retailing at 90 dollars yeah yes
yes yes yes yes well you got them all
right
50 you got 100 out of 100.
[Music]